うん
re
ankoro
皆さんこんにちはえ
私は今回ですね初めてこの鹿児島というところ行ってきました
以前からとても楽しみにしていましてそして
へ
桜島がですねまぁ正面に見えることをちょっと奮発して宿をとりました
鹿児島に住んでいる皆さんにとっては見られた当たり前の光景かもしれませんが私の
ように初めてこの地を訪れる人間にとってはとても新鮮で決して当たり前のことでは
ないんですね
自分にとって当たり前のことが他の人にとって当たり前とは限らないし今
当たり前のことが将来当たり前とも限らないわけですね
例えばみなさん自分のお母さんの結婚する前の苗字
答えられますか
これほとんど1答えられますよね
当たり前だと思うかもしれない
じゃあおばあちゃんの急逝はどうでしょうか
これ意外と答えられる人少ないんですね
おばあちゃんにとってこんな当たり前のことことが私たち孫の代になるとあまり伝わっ
ていないということは私たちのこともそう遠くない将来
どんどん忘れられてしまうと思いませんか
私たちは今このネットワーク社会という時代がきています
painter ネットやスマートフォンの普及で横へどんどん
つながるということがとても得意なんですね
友達や仲間がどんどんできていきます
しかし一方で縦のつながりというものがあります
世代をつなぐこの縦のつながりというのがちょっと希薄になっているんじゃないかと
思うことがあります
この縦のつながりとても大切だと思うんですね
過去を知りそして未来を愛する心
100年後200年後のために
例えば木を植えそして水をあげるようなそういう考え方や生き方が大切だと思うんです
ね
しかし私たちは
自分たちが得することばかりに夢中になって未来を犠牲にしていないだろうか
この盾を縦のつながりを大切にする心
みんなが持てば世の中がもっと良くなっていくんじゃないかと思うんですね
私はこの縦のつながりというものをとても関心を持ってきました
それはなぜかというと
私自身の history 2
理由があるんですね
今から130年前
東京の日本橋というところで私のひいおじいちゃんは出版社をはじめました
当時は教科書を作っていたんですね
そして2代目3代目
祖父や父の代になって
今度は文芸とか文学と言われる出版社に切り替わっていったんですね
この写真は今から50数年前にとらえた写真です
私の父祖父そしてサッカーの人たちが映っています
あれをつけるかわかりますよ
右て白い服を着てちょっとこうのけぞっているのはこれ三島由紀夫ですね
その奥にいるおじいさん
川端康成です
そして左側顎に手を当てているのは井上靖
その隣手前黒縁の眼鏡をかけてちょっと分厚い唇-1
そう松本清張ですねはい持ちに文豪と呼ばれるような人たちと私の父や祖父は一緒に
仕事をしていました
しかし130年の歴史の中で実は会社は2回倒産しそして
会社の名前もにどう変わっているんですね
この2回目の父さんの時に会社は人の手に渡ってしまいました
ですから私は4代目として生まれたんですが大勝することはできませんでした
父はお前にこの会社を継ぐつなぐことができなくて申し訳ない
非常に苦悩していたんですね
私はそんな父の姿を見ながら育ってきました
そしていつかこのお父さん喜ばせてあげたいな思いだと
そしてもう一つ代々続いてきたものが途絶えてしまうと切れてしまうということは
悲しいことなんだ
そういうふうに思いだったんですねこれがわたし自身の原点なんですね
私は社会人になってそして30代の前半で小さな出版社を作りました
若者文化の流行に乗って全国の書店に漫画とか小説を
出版して発売してました
しかしこの出版もですねええ
非常にですね今非常にあの厳しくなりそして
へ
この会社を続けていくことが難しくだったわけです
なぜかというと私自身が自分が得することばかりに夢中になってたからだと思うんです
ね
そんなある時私はあるお世話になった方が病に倒れそして
帰らぬ人となったんです
お葬式の時に何か追悼できる本が作れないかという話が持ち上がって私はひと肌脱ぐ
つもりでこの本の編集を引き受けたんですね
1年かけで友人知人から原稿を集め
そしてご遺族から写真をお借りしてこの本を作ったんですね
一周忌の法事の時にこの本を一人ずつ手で配ってきました
ある人はとても喜びある人はとても懐かし階
中には涙を流して私に握手を求めてくる人もいたんです
私は今まで本を作る仕事を長くやってきてこんなに人に喜んでもらったことはなかっ
それまで本というのは全国の書店に本が並ばなくちゃいけない
本が売れて利益をあげなきゃいけないそういうふうに決め付けていたんですね
でもこの本には
定価もなければ出版社の名前も入っていません
しかし目の前にいる人はこの本を手にしてとても喜んでくれて
名もなき人の人生を綴ったこの
しかし人を
喜ばせたり人の心をつかむことができる
私はこの時ですね
初めてこの個人の人生を綴った本というものに興味を持ったんですね
これが私と自分史というものとの出会いがあったんですね
今自分史というのは非常に注目を集めつつあります
自分史に関する方も結構出版されるようになっています
自分史の作り方や普及を伝える自分史活用アドバイザーという資格も全国に300人の
人が活躍しています私もその一人
そして自分史フェスティバルというイベントも毎年開かれるようになりました
私は1万人以上の人が東京の会場を訪れたんですね
そんな自分史なんですけれどもよくこういうことを言われることがあります
自分史っていうのは自己満足のために書くんじゃないのとか
遺言の代わりに各もんでしょう私そんな年じゃないから関係ないよ
もちろん書いた人が満足することは大切です
ご年配の方が人生の締めくくりに
本を書くこともいいと思うんですね
しかし自分史というのは必ず必ずしもそれだけではないと思うんですね
敵を紹介したいのは今年の夏に作ったひとつの自分史です
命光ると聞いという風
著者は本まりえさんという
鳥の母親です
このお母さんには一人の男の元気な男の子がいます
光太郎くんと言います
6歳の頃まで元気に走り回ってた男の子です
ところがある日突然体に異変が起こるんですね
そして今までできていたことができなくなるん
落ち着きがなくなったり奇声を発するようになったり
要するおかしいと思ってお母さん色々な病院に連れて来ました原因がなかなかわかり
ません
そして大きな病院で宣告を受けるんですね
お母さんはこの病気は
母親の遺伝子が原因で
男の子にしか発症しない
とても珍しい難病です
一度発症すると1年か2年で命を落とすことがほとんどなんです
お母さん目の前が真っ暗になりました
愛する我が子が自分の遺伝子が原因です
こんなに苦しいん
お母さんは自分を責め続けたんですね
しかしこの病気というのは
治療薬はまだ見つかっていないしかし進行を食い止めるには骨髄移植が有効だという
ことがわかっ
たまたまお姉さんの2水が一致して手術が成功するんですね
しかしこの男の国はとても重たい障害が残ってしまいました
自分で体を動かすことはできません
会話もすることができません
お母さんの心が晴れることはありませんでした
街で同じ年頃の男の子を見かけると胸が張り裂けそうになりそして涙が止まらなくなっ
たといいます
そして自分なんかも消えてしまいたいそういうふうに思ったそうです
そんなある時街をフラフラ歩いている時にお母さん車にはねられてしまうんですね
目が覚めると病院のベッドの上でした
その時お母さんをなぜ自分が助かったんだろう
なぜ自分が生かされたんだろうということを考えるようだと
この日を境にお母さんは化粧してそして家族のために手料理を振る舞え
趣味の生花を始めました
なぜ変わったと思うでしょうか
男の子が毎日元気にしているお母さんを見るのと化粧もせずに
目の下にクマを作って毎日ごめんなさいと言いながら
環境するのと男の子は言葉は話せないけれど
どちらのお母さんの姿を見たいでしょうか
お母さんそのことに気がついたんですね
そしてお母さんは
自分の人生になぜこの難病というテーマが与えられたのか
自分の人生の役割というのは何なのかということを考えるようになった
5してお母さんをですね同じ難病に苦しむ患者や家族のため全国の患者家族のために
呼びかけて患者会を作りました
この鹿児島にも足を運びそして鹿児島で同じように苦しんでる悩んでいるお母さんと
連絡を取り合い励まし合う
そういうことにも取り組んでいます
今は全国の大学病院から声がかかり講演活動にも取り組んでいるわけですね
こうしたお母さんの赤裸々な人生を綴った自分史
決して自己満足のためでもなければ遺言でもない理由
世代を越えてこの本はきっと読み継がれていくと私は思うんです
それはつまりですねこうした本というのを私は演習を手伝っていて
改めて自分史というものは何なのかということを考えるようになったわけです
自分史というのは文字通り自分の歴史なんですね
しかしこの自分史
書くためにはまず自分のヒストリー過去を見なくちゃいけない
だから自分史っていうのは自分を見ることなんですね
そして自分を見ることによって見えてくるのが
志
自分の志が見えてきたら今度はこの自分の人生をなのために使うのか
この命をなのために使うか
自分の使い方が見えてくる
さっきのお母さん自分の使命こういうものに気がつきそしてスイッチが入ったように
全国で活動を始めました
自分の使い方は分かれば人は動き始めるわけです
つまり自分史を書くことによって本当の自分
あるいは新しい自分を始めるこれが自分史の役割のひとつの大きないいじゃないかと
思うんですね
そして私自身もなぜ
代々続く出版社を注ぎ損ねたのか
そこが私のきっとテーマなんじゃないかなと思うんですね
今日はちょっと簡単な自分史の作り方を一つ紹介したいと思います名付けて一枚の自分
史と言います
ぜひ皆さんお家に帰って取り組んでほしいんですけれども
家の中に眠っている古いアルバムから写真を取り出してください
そしてこの写真からどれだけのエピソードを紡ぎ出せるのか
挑戦してほしいんですね
例えばいつどこで誰と撮った写真なのか
そしてその写真を
音や匂い
味
ぬくもり五感を使って感じ取って欲しいですね
そしてその写真が撮られた時代世の中ではどんな出来事があっただろうか
どんな歌が流行ったかどんな流行語が使われていたか
ニュースでは町町はどんなニュースで賑わっていたか
自分が生きた時代と世の中の出来事を関連付けることも自分史の楽しみ方の一つなん
ですね
そして
その写真からどんな感情が沸き起こる買う
喜び悲しみ怒り感謝ものもしこの写真が撮らえた時代に戻れるなら誰にどんな言葉を
かけてあげたいか
そんなことに思いをめぐらせてみるのもいいかもしれません
この1枚の自分史ぜひ自分一人じゃなくてですね
家族と一緒に取り組んでほしいですね
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんそしてお孫さんも一緒に
この写真おじいちゃんなにああそうだ思い出したらこの時はねこんな会話を楽しみ
ながらですね
1枚の自分史が5枚10枚20枚
そうやって増えていけばきっとそれはみなさんにとってかけがいのない自分史
家族しになっていくと思うんですね
私はこの自分しか属しというものが
どこの家庭でも作られるようになったらいいなと思っています
そうすれば最初の質問おばあちゃんの急逝はきっと皆さん応えられると思うんですね
それはつまり未来のために木を植えそして水をあげる
そういう考え方に通じてくると思います
さあこの自分史というもの
自分の人生の役割に気づかせることがあります
人を
元気にさせる力もあるかもしれません
そして次の時代へ
よ見つられていく役割を果たすこともできると思います
そしてこの自分史というのは皆さん一人ひとりの中に必ず持っているものなんですね
しかしこの自分史というものを
書かずに人生を終える人がほとんど
この自分史を書くかどうかはもちろん皆さん次第なんです
ただこれだけは言えると思うんですね
今日
まさしく今
この瞬間も私たちの自分史というのは
現在進行形ということです
私の話はこれで終わります